welcome to this video yeah this is about
round five of tata steel 2013 and this
round saw the clash of the 2m tournament
leaders world champion vishy anand
against world number one by rating
Magnus Carlsen and unfortunately it
wasn't such a thrilling game which also
might be due to the fact that damned if
you read retail on the German side that
Carson obviously I wasn't feeling so
well today even I consulted a doctor in
the morning maybe I don't know caught
some cold or something in the on the
free day um yeah ate something that you
didn't really am yeah handled so well
you don't know but those things are you
when they happen and sometimes they
really influenced the the games um but
nevertheless cards and being black gum
certainly he didn't really am mind the
draw let's say let's say this way he's
only wouldn't play some some know
swashbuckling stuff to to try to
surprise some okay we had a Petrov maybe
this is really due to the fact that
Klaus wasn't feeling so well it's not
exactly the kind of opening where you
fight for something um I mean for for
some sharp play way you can win that
it's really a solid line and to see them
the main line here and now cars and even
um avoids any kinds of main line by
going Bishop to e7 the normal moopheus
d5 of course and then it can get really
theoretical with them Bishop d3 and like
now playing knight c6 or should be seven
and later see for this is some very
forcing opening or you need to memorize
some lots of concrete variation
and um oops I did this again and cousin
just play Bishop II sandwich is also
known move of course but look at what's
happening he just sets up a slightly
passive position which is tough to break
down night three through v8 and 93 de
smooth surprised me a bit I would really
expect y to play with the sea for this
position to to grab the center with
pawns but this is also a bit dumb yeah
bit of a matter of taste maybe em I'm
always a player who likes to put parts
in the center so for me see for and then
93 looks much more natural but ok the
world champion played 93-97 rupee one
and yeah blankets in a bit of a traffic
jam on the Queen's that he wants to
transfer the night over to g6 and then
complete its development yeah d5 this is
probably the only way um for wide to to
go forward and in some way if you would
just develop it's hard to get anything
let's say you would just develop piece
like this like probably would play
something like c6 and just continue in
this in this slightly passive but solid
fashion like this and try to exchange on
the e-file this is in fact very solid
for black and it's certainly am a good
alternative maybe to the main line of
you don't mind to this slightly cramped
positions ok d 5 c 6 yeah he wants to
battle this d5 pawn to break up this
central dominance by white and we'll see
Bishop f4 there should be seven yeah
white
needs to control this point winning a
tempo in group c 8 so Lex got all stuff
in play so wyd looks a little bit better
of course with the space advantage and
the nicely positioned pieces yeah but
it's hard to to keep this point all the
time um like was intending to probably
take and we get a similar position like
in the game this looks like white should
be able to preserve a lil somethin a
dumb in the game it didn't really
materialize why took and Bishop takes ya
know what I'm to fear you cannot give up
d6 Bishop takes and now it looks like
this pawn is weak in fact liked him
instantly advances the 2i to d5 and now
we have got an isolated power position
in which um and this is the weak spot in
blacks camp but he's got some things
going for him as well at the post
possible 94 moose I can activate the
bishop on some some squares I don't
think that white should have too much
yeah like isn't one bed and development
also look on the C file already so on
this should be a very slightly better
for why the best at the Queen d3 Queen B
6 yeah itm in this position on add them
to Conti 5 here here maybe is the point
where you should or could look for for
improvements for white as this capture
doesn't really um leat led to anything
could think about them just centralizing
but it's not clear that white has got
anything concrete going home yeah this
is one of those position which is
what has kind of symbolic advantage but
it's it's really not much like it's very
very solid I think something like this
was more testing though if you look at
what happened i think i'm on maybe
thought he could could get a little bit
of something with the more activity with
the better activity you look at this and
now black in order to main the material
equality needs to grab and look at this
is a roxy to UM it was also possibility
but maybe it is not as good 95 isn't it
a bit annoying to look at this possible
rook rook to e1 it's annoying on the
e-file so he took on be to cook a b2
Queen takes and rook takes and probably
I'm honored hoped that he would have
something here but in fact it doesn't
materialize whoop dat queen bee three
other it's not not much else where else
would you go queen bee three Queen takes
a takes be yeah and here the jaw was
already agreed on I would say I'm
probably a Manas proposal as it was his
move last um yeah there simply is not
much going on here black can play Bishop
c5 which is certainly I would have done
and keep this pawn safely protected also
you've got a possible Bishop b6 sort of
anchoring it on b6 and that's not not
much going on on the queenside the only
thing you have to see here it's 9 g5
maybe Islander could have could have
tried this but here black needs to find
the strong move group to d5 attacking
the snide with the point that night x +
7 designs of pyruvate
and this night that doesn't have any
squares it has the five but this leads
to a problem on on the f 2 square with
the bishop and and rook staring down so
after this white needs to go before and
we have some operation like this coming
with complete complete equality it's
equal parts and nothing happening yeah
this is what is the probably the most
logical continuation of all this but
obvi she offered to draw himself I don't
know I didn't have didn't see any
footage maybe cards was really so so um
well positioned I mean from from from
the health perspective that we she
didn't want to want to touch him longer
he's really a nice guy probably this is
a booze is a possibility really um but I
don't know what was what was happening a
bit of a disappointment you would hope
for fireworks but it sometimes happens
if you watch other sports those big
clashes on paper sometimes I real
disappointment and some players or teams
neutralize each other all right um a
drawn but believe me the other games had
lots of action so it was the great round
let's go to kayaking against the Giri
next kayaking playing a default slide
surprise here it's a nearfall player but
he very some once in a while with
default to be unpredictable or less
predictable and Gilliam we have g6 some
signaling for green felt and f3 the same
somewhat exotic looking line um has
become pretty much mainstream nowadays
especially after uninduced it in the
world championship match against galfond
and
gear we actually played the pure goon
felt move d 5 black has other options if
just for the black player if you want
something creative than 96 is a cool
idea the idea being after you fall to go
b5 and you've got completely yeah
ungroomed felt position but it's it's
very dynamic and interesting ok but give
replayed t5 the main roof and now we
have this typical horn center but the
White has played f3 instead of Knight c3
which means that the night cannot
capture on c3 and still go back and this
is all very standard Queen d2 the hip
like has many options see when tonight
c6 attacking um deform and white plate
long castle the sharpest move yeah and
here black again has a couple of firm
alternatives you played queen d 6 which
is some preparing rook e8 increasing
pressure on d4 yeah I looked this up
before I did the video to get some idea
what is because frankly speaking I have
no idea about this opening especially
considering if you look at that the
following moves not be 527 the set has
been played before f4 and the Queen e6
and this looks completely weird to me
and so so far off my usual arm chest
taste that I have absolutely no idea
what's going on yeah let's say 97 is
this a move Queen takes here and the
problem is after Knight takes a 8
there's not a 5 and black as some is
even winning yeah there's really a weird
weird things and chest theory nowadays
97 seems to be bad the other move you
could look at it of course d5 but then
like can take here
and now Bishop f5 leads to leads to
disaster so I'm 26 a purely tactical
move wider returns and canvas the two
coupons and black now uses the gain term
control over C 422 blanc in this night
and why doesn't take it he rather gives
up this Bishop then then they have one
Bishop and to make things worse I mean
just from a static point if you black
now plate 98 to a five and this is
really weird chest in my book but okay
um it is obviously working I mean
blackest love blown of the board in our
attack the center will see 5 at last
something I am I do understand d 5 and
now black gum clarified the situation a
bit with taking yeah the point is the
night ISM attacking only three so that
there's no great discovery by this night
and if white would try to prepare this
like I'm 95 let's say we play here then
black has the technical shot Bishop g4
this is annoying cannot take here
because of cheek need this one and then
if you go here then you really didn't
gain much like an just move the Queen
and intend to to even now used to beep
on its own it's not great so you went 95
instantly and black can't took it and
wide return so um white has this idea
and this is coming and I black simply
returned amazingly on the point of this
is that now Wyatt can play Knight f6
shake which um looks good at first sight
the kind of hope that you play instantly
in blitz but let's say black takes
I mean let's say it's the only move
takes takes rook takes and their white
has won the Queen but it's a question if
this really helped them it probably
needs to take now and now black has all
kinds of active ideas you can go Bishop
here rook c8 or 90 form and this in fact
looks pretty good for black then come I
would prefer black in this position it's
probably around equal but just seems
easier to play yeah 28 and the just g3
strengthening the position yeah it's
remarkable Geary was down to 16 minutes
in so this is what's the main problem i
would say white again can win the Queen
but it says simply um get Surrey allowed
to to the situation I described earlier
white doesn't really want to win the
Queen and now it stepped out again to a
five and yeah if you look at this just
trauma first thought you would say that
white is somewhat better with the those
nicely position lights the morrow d5 is
very very very nice and Bishop on g7
doesn't look too active but if you look
at this book here and King evades a good
prophylactic move to step out of the
checks like not f6 or 90 x + 7 which
technically can be M can be very very
annoying yeah it looks like white should
be better but somehow it doesn't
materialize and then the game just this
and black is slowly improving in fact
them here with b5 before black its own
completely utilizing and we had some
further exchanges coming ya know a draw
was agreed yeah black doesn't have any
any some problems anymore this
the Queen covers those two slide
weaknesses and like as some has two
bishops my may be possible to to
activate this somewhat later but it's
really not much happening in this
position g5 maybe an idea okay draw a
grid and frankly speaking the other
games were far more interesting so let's
get to get to the other ones um okay we
had even local off playing levon aronian
and the cool off playing DeForest usual
but live on coming up with a surprise he
plays the groom felt which he sometimes
does but not very often and the cloth
plays Bishop g5 which is a bit cheeky
because Aronian assume the biggest
expert in this line this is his pet line
is white and the Caliph just plays it
himself now I didn't really check if the
cool off also goes for the slime
dragonlily I think he usually plays he
takes d5 okay but um let's see what
happened Bishop g7 by Aronian which is
an interesting move it looks a bit
strange at first because you would
imagine that why I can just win a pawn
but this is in fact not good even
because now after Bishop g7 black thread
and c6 or e6 to get the porn back and it
is impossible for white to to hold it in
the long run so let's say something like
this night m3 lender c5 coming III and
something like this the problem is once
this night moves d for faults and it's
not possible to prevent it something
like like this year and at the end black
black has the bishop pair and what extra
porn in the center with a very
comfortable position
so this is quite an interesting move I'm
white can try to to take here take what
the pond and this sir leads to quite
interesting lines I had to look at this
years ago it's quite interesting okay um
but um sokoloff played Knight f3 and
this allows knight to e form and we now
and supposed to align with usually
arises after for Knight f3 and we should
be five on the fifth move you should
have form and then takes takes takes I'm
not quite sure what the khulafa
preparation walsim this is a rather rare
line already usually this some position
comes up with the bishop here like this
and then a form in the game we had the
same position with the bishop here and
this is really somewhat different as the
bishop on H Freud least put some
pressure on the seven porn the bishop on
f4 is not doing much really and frankly
speaking I don't really get white some
opening idea if you look in a couple of
moves it looks like he simply has has
nothing but problems ready for now could
also consider just to take with the
Queen and maybe this was wiser decision
just playing form for a solid simple
position like c5 III keeping small but
but stable center look what's happening
you play deformed c5 Bishop takes
certain is the more ambitious choice but
look here yeah the problem is he now
cancelled and this surrender submission
Pam if you are but if you look at this
what should should do i do if you want
to keep her the bishops let's say you
move the bishop back in preparation then
there's this
nasty shot and you have problems before
as hanging and yeah what should you play
if Quincy too then there's not ecigs and
this night just helps to win upon it
looks looks grim here what needs to play
something very unnatural like giving up
the bishop this fields like something
white certainly didn't intend and here
are black should be fine already with
the two bishops they'd be 61 plan right
played d5 yeah important point is that
if white would try to capture here that
black doesn't really need to worry about
this because this opens up the position
for the bishops and you can easily
sacrifice a pony on the queenside for
example with the bishop six on or even
you should to be seven c7 they ideas
like in quincy a doll so something like
this all right with them why plate them
my wishes move d 5 which was answered by
60 a typical attacking the center h3
yeah probably a.m. because of this
possibility after an exchange but it
looks very slow for wide a five yeah and
now it's a question what should one play
he played Bishop g5 which looks like a
big mistake um and probably am white
already is in slight trouble but them
yeah probably looked do you want some
some moves like this it it's a it's a
it's better than the game man this much
is clear but it's not not fun to play um
let's say I'm takes takes and Bishop a
six it's also not
particularly great but maybe maybe it's
something like this is it's a better
chance than than the game and this G
I've got a deep on and those pawns are
not ideally placed in the game after
Bishop g5 there was just f6 this is
neither this is hanging and Bishop a 67
threatening to win the exchange and yeah
what should why do he tried to capture
and probably miscalculated somewhere
here not not sure ya rayah just went
Bishop a6 attacking the Queen and the
problem is the movie section which looks
so looks good it's a check right but
black can simply take it and in this
position you still got the exchange
hanging on everyone and the bishop so
black just wins a huge material so you
cannot go e6 ready so he went Queen to
d5 but this just leads to an exchange of
Queens and black takes the bishop of
being an extra you're having an extra
piece now just one the bishop so this is
really a weird game for a playoff circle
of strength he must have miscalculated
something around here and certainly
wasn't just satisfied with the position
anyway so in the game let's jump ahead
like I just needed to bump this up
swiftly and we managed to do so quite
quickly now he reside you cannot keep
the pawns even I mean those two pawns
always slide hope but let's say d6 black
just goes through b5 and attacks both
poles either the boat opponent and the
night and you will lose some of this
material so bit of a disaster for for
Zocalo who's really a strong player um
alright so next game but good for
Aronian he really needed a win to get
going into this
he played brilliant tournament last year
but didn't really yeah get into the flow
one up to now in this in this one okay
we had another game who you found
against Nakamura which yeah which has
some a clear idea about Nakamura I guess
win a game this is sadly the case for
who you found was a bit of an outsider
in this field and everyone wants to win
against her maybe yeah I don't know
maybe it's a better strategy to to play
in a more solid fashion and try to yeah
let let people yeah play for win and
positions where it's not really a really
feasible but she's really fighting
against those guys setting up
complicated positions but it's not
working up to now okay now camera went
for as a Solian end we got with the all
the transposition a dragon yeah here
nakamura played the somewhat rare lined
with a six oops a six and mg 6 and this
is rarely played and I'm very far away
from being an expert so i won't i won't
be able to judge the theoretical
implications so black plays Knight to a
five to get to get this Bishop end y
term goes for this exchange which makes
sense like took and now played a five
which is an interesting strategical
concept getting rid of the bishop on g7
which is basically strong piece but
after the exchange black is able to
place this pawn on e5 um before this
would have killed the bishop but now
that the bishop is off so if five looks
good and gets this night away from the
center so drops back and now be five
yeah this is a position num which
looks more like an idol I am especially
confident way um the unusual thing is
that white hasn't canceled she canceled
long quickly is an interesting point
before yeah here she played a night to a
form and this is I know I really don't
like it maybe that's not not a great
alternative but then i would simply i
would really prefer that d5 don't like
to put it on the edge of the board maybe
i don't know what what black would play
probably here check just putting some
some moves on the board this one a
problem is that also this night is not a
great piece am at all where where should
it go it doesn't have a clear route I
mean it would be nice I maybe III mp3
would be a good good square yeah this is
a possibility wife could try to to put
this on III only three it would cover
see to have a d5 this would be a good
good place yeah but maybe it let's say
something like this castles Bishop II
and I know 93 with this intention um
it's certainly am NOT threatening for
black but it looks rather solid in the
game after this night a father just tell
have a look at this position black took
her five castles long and rook Essex and
now you you ask yourself what is this
not doing it would it will never go to
be six black has just covered this and
yeah maybe it can go to c5 a tactical
way some some somewhere along along the
way but it doesn't have any natural
square to go to and it just feels wrong
it's good to get this piece are they for
yeah probably it's not so bad for white
but I don't like it just from from from
personal taste okay she went h4 there
should be six h5 you had the typical
H file opener yeah Knight takes is
probably a bad idea giving wide some one
or this one first I don't know and then
and then night then Queen age six and g5
coming yeah black gap has no interest in
taking this Queenie 7g form and Niger to
d7 yeah and here I think not so much is
going on but look what happens next she
played f4 now and I don't know I think
black is comfortable no doubt about it
this night is not playing but black also
has pieces here too to make sure that
it's not plain and I don't think that
white is so bad in this position if she
should just play some some normal moves
like King here and slightly improving
also may be thinking about this night it
hasn't got much to do also maybe even
here this is an idea to transfer to e3
yeah like certainly doesn't have any
trouble but um yeah but in the game she
played f4 and this is probably just a
miscalculation like just took the pawn
and after f5 also grab this one and okay
it opens up the position but it doesn't
lead to an attack black always has got
the simple move Knight to f6 and this
covers everything it's simply a point of
at some point of logic because well this
night is not helping you play without
this piece and you only have one minor
piece of only two that may be helping in
the tech but this is really little and
look at this G takes f takes and now
black just went off the default and
covered this somewhat loose piece and
the black is just a pawn up for nothing
and it's even
positional advantage if you look what's
coming we form Queenie 5 and now you see
that black has a very active Queen this
night is stable on f6 it cannot be
attacked by a pond and g4 just covered
it has even a great square on f3 coming
so this is probably just winning for
black and nakamura I did a good job and
mopping this up he had some alternatives
but this was always good for plea
advantage look at this night gap like as
the extra foam and the better activity
of the rooks check yeah this is coming
and those pawns are are weaker then
blacks counterparts check and resigned
yeah simply after it takes takes
Blackwell will win both pawns and have
an easy and game win yeah sort of a
strange game I think this this this f4
move is just based on some
miscalculation and I'm not sure um what
miscalculation none exactly some not
clear to me it also feels this is
putting this night on a form doesn't
feel right to me maybe you should should
really go to d5 and it's it's the
admission that you don't have much but
i'd rather have very little and solid
position then play with us off sat night
I don't know it looks a look strange to
me but the real problem was of course
this FY of you don't play that and play
some solid move instead it or should be
still quite okay alright so next game
allow me against one huh
check BOGO Indian the bogo Indiana some
rather rare guest at the top level it's
not so bad though it has some quite
interesting lines let's say here here
and this was played in the game this is
an interesting way to play for black if
you want to get slight imbalance on the
board without risking too much um yeah
white captures and black captures and
this looks did we add it first because
you allowed a capture away from the
center and you have this somewhat loose
porn on before but the idea is that this
porn nicely controls the natural
development squares for the for the
night and like in fact if you if you
look what what's going on often as this
set up on the queenside which has the
long-term plan of playing 'if I've and
provoking some move of the deep on so
that blacks night can even jump to c5
later and it cannot be attacked by
before of course because black has upon
himself on before so this is a rather
interesting strategical position which
black and can play 2 to get a little bit
of an imbalance and try to play for win
it's not better for black not saying
this but it's something where you can
play form form for complications later
yeah Quincy 7220 look look very standard
would be eight and now we five young and
um I'm not so sure that I like whites
play but it probably wasn't wasn't so
bad yeah this is interesting black gum
tickles the snide a bit and provokes
this before move you should reform f3
another pointless and Bishop e7 and
I think in the next couple of moves y
term yeah what simply it goes wrong and
some may be around here that you need to
to look for for better for better set up
this e 4 3 is not too ammonius anyway
but um if you look what happens it
really gets gets problematic we have
this exchange now of course defaults
hanging white needs to do something if
you would try to protect it then there's
this annoying pin coming it's not not
too great and you don't want to play
oops you don't want to play d5 as this
concedes the c5 Square and black also
has got them through gate to coming so
in the game you played queen bee three
attacking this pawn like answered with
the natural move Queen B 6 yeah and here
defaults are just staying this way so
why the needs to do some something
radical and t1 c5 like took it and yeah
now why them went for some complete
transformation of the pawn structure but
this is limbs since seems too early to
to some trouble if you will take here
then like them yet doesn't have any
particular problems than sequin here
where it still looks fairly solid for
white and the game let this go in here
and now a capsule on e5 which leads to
the the rare occasion that you've got
here five pounds five against three
against three against one and the issue
is queen here the issue is that those
pawns can be really really quick and
white now needs to be very very careful
in fact what he was playing I think
yeah it's very close to a loss and then
quickly maybe I'm here there were
alternatives like Queen here the idea
being if you look at this to play
something along these lines keep the
Queen's on it's not a brilliant position
also but maybe this is better than the
game in the game he played Queen here b5
and 92 and then c4 and now you see that
the Queen's get exchanged he also could
go to d6 by the way which is somewhat
better than the game but also a good for
black here the Queen's off and now you
have got this essential problem those
majorities on the King side we're both
Kings arm I can sometimes be a dangerous
weapon like f4 f5 but this involves
twins on the board because you want to
have some attack on the King later um
and here in this situation there are no
Queen so what we'll never get an attack
with the spawns on the other hand black
has this promise and is very very
quickly in getting a passed pawn yep or
even two best bonds and this is hard to
stop look what's happening and here we
go that's the first passport and black
even ask up to and yeah this is already
already gone not defensible and it's
also really easy like just needs to push
the pawns and in fact he played it
played it rather nicely after work t8 he
could also go for some some some
covering move like Bishop e7 but black
doesn't even need to meet this night
just play g6 once you took it gives you
seven yeah and now white needs to take
care about the pawns and yeah
he repositioned the bishop work to d7
night here and now the very cute
finishing touch check rook to e1 check
and TM after 91 c 2 white reside with it
and this is a very cute now black
threatens to queen in three ways and
three ways that's really too much quite
quite nice so I'm rather not a nice win
for one how I think somewhere around
here was white White's mistake not one
hundred percent sure probably am here
Quincy to was better instead of Queen
III but I really don't like this efore
f3 thing maybe I'm this already was a
bit a bit shaky it seems to lead to a
loose position in the center all right
I'm still interesting this game ok so
now let's go for a lick o against Cara
wanna and we got a window pass again get
this fashionable line with d3 no one
wants to play the marshal yeah this is
the main response nowadays that that I
play myself actually it was black C 3
cancels Bishop c2 yeah this is
interesting the bishop see to move here
prophylactically removes the bishop
against 95 yeah come on i played before
here rookie one Andrew create ya hear
there's also an alternative taking n t5
this has been played 2 times x um
British Grand Master Michael Adams Santi
he drew both games I don't want to get
into a big theoretical
discussion here but this kind of
approach looks looks more active at
least the thing is kiwana gets into a
pretty standard looking Royal position
but it's it's very uncomfortable
suddenly I'm not quite sure where and
where the mistake is this looks look
still very normal 95 this is a typical
idea you want to use the seaport white
cannot take on before laughter knight c6
you get before back and have a good term
change of the bone structure on the
queenside so what I mean is deform and
now a couple of moves like you go see
five and this was the idea of 9 a-5 this
is some fairly standard structure which
should be slightly slightly better for
white but not not a big deal from black
and to be honest I'm not quite sure
where he went wrong because some couple
of moves later black gum really has got
a very uncomfortable position a problem
is white always has the c4 square and a
couple of moves later we see writer was
able to play a form a 5 preventing
Knight b6 and this means white will
install a night on c4 which cannot be a
driven away and black also couldn't play
a 6 a-5 him service this would concern
would surrender b5 also not what you
want so this is really a man annoying
position he tried of course to relieve
the pressure by exchanging something
like this and now queen queen e 2 which
is a good move here Bishop c2 was also
interesting keeping this on the board um
it was what's an idea at least maybe am
white didn't like didn't like this
ability okay but Queenie to is perfectly
all right what liquor was aiming for is
this position exactly this structure the
structure is really a problem for black
the night especially is such a great
piece it cannot be yeah driven away from
this disc where it covers a 5 this
annoying porn that always controls b6
and also this night controls an
important be 2 square where black rook
might pop up at some point and based on
this white some night basically secures
the hawk who inside the problem is that
black has no play at all and we see that
he can not do much more than shuffling
around and as mentioned I'm not quite
sure how he got into this where he could
could improve I mean this is not them
the kind of position you should get as
black it's not so bad this whole setup
but somewhere around along the last
couple of moves he must have gone wrong
I'm not able to determine relief and the
computer doesn't understand the position
simply it if you look at this with with
the computer it will tell you that this
is around equal and this is complete
nonsense white is clearly better um you
again you might have 3,300 on some list
but if it tells you this is equal it has
no idea about chess white is clearly
better alright we can go add a couple of
moves and this is the problem while the
Queen side is securely am configured by
why it cannot like you will never get
anything here White has chances on the
King side plus F formed and can easily
improve now allowing to recapture with
the porn if you want it's got all the
time in the world kingi to
develop here okay it's better to double
on the G file no problem white ass all
the time in the world or black can just
shuffle um you have no one way to get
out of the pore structures black taking
on air force basically never an option
and yeah what what should you do cannot
cannot do much while white is preparing
the further advance on the King side in
fact here white went for a five and has
this idea coming while Black is just
passive in fact the computer still only
gives white a very slight advantage
which is rather amazing OKH form yeah I
think here he played the Queen d7 with
little time on the clock probably the
toughest defense here was the very very
passive but yeah maybe necessary night
2h7 the idea being to play Bishop to e7
and play f6 which is super ugly but at
least them it secures the king side for
the time being um and this is some not
easy to break down actually um and
probably what you should have done in
the game it goes downhill very quickly
27 and now the very strong g form the
point is that black cannot capture on h4
because of g5 and there's not nothing
better than this after which black
cannot hold g7 if you would play g6 in
this position then queen age three SS
deadly with various threats rook here or
queen age 6 + f6 it's too much note that
really this night is keeping everything
shourouk b2m so it's just captured and
like his black is toast here so g4 was
strong because it simply wins time you
don't need to waste any time to protect
h4 you can just go ahead and push pawns
and Kara wanna down to two minutes now
played this which probably accelerate
things but you need to stop this and
this was the move that he could come up
with in two minutes and cakes and g5
very strong logical play by Lake we're
opening it up and now we see that the
rocks are positioned excellently on the
G farm against the king and h5 and after
the simple captcha Caruana resigned he
simply has no move wyd them will just
win with the Kings Ida take what should
black do here you would take on g6
there's there's various moves you could
just if you want drop this back end and
to win those pieces on the G file like
has no defense at all yeah very nice
strategical win by likkle who really
dominated this game I mean to be honest
as mentioned before i'm not sure where
black really went wrong it was probably
no big mistake one big mistake but a
couple of small M inaccuracies what I do
know is that this kind of position is a
nightmare and it also shows that
computers sometimes to misjudge
positions and quite quite a dramatic
fashion to give this as equal or 0.2 or
something it's quite remarkable and some
this is basically not playable for black
you just you will just suffer and maybe
draw a couple of games but use most of
them least for you minutes it's torture
to play this
alright so we we have through six games
and there's still one game open hi
Krishna against then really let's put
this up and this was also interesting we
had a good run today only the yeah on
paper most interesting cave are not
God's was a slight disappointment the
rest was interesting chess ok Myra
Krishna playing me for and and opens a
zillion red-bellied playing a six Lacan
variation now interesting move on a
wrinkle by Krishna be should be to which
is a rare move what why does so try to
do is he wants to play Knight c3 really
but after Knight c3 black also has the
ambitious set up with the immediate b5
and why probably wants to avoid this and
place but should be to first if black
now would play re5 white would have the
option of attacking with a form not
immediately probably but in the near
future I check the spawn at this pawn um
yeah it's not able to attack a knight on
c3 simply the night has not developed
yet and this means that v5 is pointless
really is very often the case that v5 is
a pointless move there is no night to
attack so this prevents the b5 line may
be an interesting move order for some
for some for some people of course it
allows Knight f6 Knight c3 g6 and now we
are back in this given in and set up
which could also easily come from a
night off in fact well really is a big
expert on the night off and also this
gave inning and he played this really a
lot in the past okay we have a lot of
one known theoretical moves this is well
known back from from the 80s really um
from the classic gum Kasparov against
cup of games in this case it would be
cup of against his part of cobb of being
white
and Chris power of plain black cap off
plate this classical set up with we
should be to add Bishop e3 I'm almost
exclusively against the night off enters
given in influenced by his second efrain
Geller basically is the godfather of
this system it looked some slow but in
fact I leads to very interesting
ambitious play because white plays g4 it
took him a while but he doesn't take on
the kingside g4 and this also am it
tends to play g5 asking this night where
it should go this um means that black
needs to drop this piece back to get a
square on d7 Sochi 597 and now white
goes Bishop g2 the idea is to play rook
f3 and threw 83 piling up against them
age 70 yeah this structure also was
played them in the final game of the
nineteen eighty-five World Championship
match where Karpov needed to win this
game 24 to keep the title but he didn't
manage Kasparov won and became the
thirteenth world champion so I'm really
am well known kind of setup which is
very interesting to play I think for
both sides like I do recommend this for
white players okay rook to h3 you want
to get something on the h-bond yeah yeah
preventing Queen to h5 but the Queen has
good square on each floor
all right not much choice you need to
cover this night back to f8 and this is
one key set up for black this fianchetto
end the night on f8 covering the crucial
squares here on them on the Kings side
Queen back to f2 attacking b6 and
blacker went back yeah here's some a
position where white could make a troll
with green edge for but of course he he
doesn't intend this he played for
further attack rook f1 preparing f5 so
white has got his rooks and Queen
shifted against the king only the nights
have been a bit off here keeping the
Queen side together controlling the
center um yeah I think here next move
night before to us I don't like it but
then it seems at least after quick
analysis visor to me to drop this night
back and help with the defense white
could we could play a bishop deform like
in the game but for example on Bishop g4
um guy takes takes and Roxy a juster the
sample lines not forced at all then the
night only seven at least has a look on
the f5 square so if white would try to
push this now then you could get
something like this just to just check
sample yang directly one here even so
maybe this move and and I'm Ruby five
controlling g5 so the lighter helped in
defense and then this looks better to me
than to place it on before if you look
at the gammy plate this is matching
night before move and after Bishop
deform like a exchange and went back
with this piece and
one this is already em some sort of
admission of failure that you will need
to need to go back I mean you need to do
this really because you need to defence
a piece but probably as you should have
gone to be seven in the first place f5
yeah white needs to open up the air farm
and this is an important move that maybe
some some more cautious players some
would shy away from because you can see
d 5 square replace them the night only
five it considers of course important
central square but without the f porn
you are not able to make any progress in
this position and this is why you must
play it you must give your looks some
some purpose on this squares so f5s is
important is push ok Knight to e5 and
here I Krishna played Queen to h4 which
is of course a logical move and probably
also a good move h5 yeah in fact i think
this this move is probably am is
probably losing but it's it's very
tricky and how I Krishna I didn't didn't
play play the Nollan move here I mean I
think he could could have just done we
played this one I think you could have
just taken and this seems good to me
they're in fact a couple of interesting
technical points in this position if
like a wood for example go to h 7 which
looks normal blocking this pawn then
white has the immediate winner night x
e6 it's quite cute takes p.m. then get
what should like do if you take with the
night then look here king and queen g5
just wins like an like an resign with
the clear conscience here this thing is
just falling
play with g8 that's Ruby g7 and Queen g6
coming like has no defense at all the a
black has not it's not forced to play
King edge 7 down there are other moves
but white retain some very dangerous
game anyway he simply opens up the the
kingside quickly often you must be
cautious with taking those pawns as
their own porn sometimes Bloxham the
yeah they haven't used for a tech so to
say but this doesn't seem to be the case
here for example also Queen dat dance
teacher 7 + f6 coming and this is also
disaster Queen age sixes problem of
course 9 t xf64 be taken care of but
possible ideas is this also so it looks
terrible I mean the computer is on plus
3 which means it's completely winning so
this seems to win what he intended is
also very logical very human he played 9
to e to the idea being Knight to f4 rg3
but f-for mostly putting pressure on
both pawns and intending to sec the
night on age 5 it looks super dangerous
dangerous and it is very dangerous yeah
let's see what happened black now took
on a 5 and 9 f form yeah and here we
have the probably critical position of
this of this game I mean he effing
really played with 15 units on the clock
he played came to g7 and I think at
least this is what I came up with
together with the computer black should
probably yeah in very cold blooded
fashion just take me form and let the
white proof that that he has something
the amazing thing about this is if white
would now sacrifice on h 5 which is
certainly the idea
takes takes takes black and play king of
eight and what doesn't seem to have from
something something decisive of course
it looks like like dodging bullets with
black but I don't see anything i compute
also not eg6 there's Ruby six can you
get a chance check play g7 but Ruby six
there there is no immediate win it seems
but of course I only looked a couple of
minutes so there maybe maybe there is
something but it but it's very
understandable that black didn't really
feel so confident and entering this the
problem is though what he played he
played King to g7 and look at this now
White has got this night jump now and
okay black needs to get rid of one night
at least this is understandable and now
with the Queen detected it grabbed on
ctools is also the best and now white
took on at five and this is now a dream
attacking position for what it's got
every piece in the attack and there's
still this idea in the position I think
it's really lost now rook c8 neither
form and this is not defensible anymore
plate king 2 h8 covering the h5 porn it
took yeah black needs to recapture to 10
96 and this is this is just a great
attacking peace king here into Bishop to
g5 yeah the thing is if black would go
to H step in which looks more natural
then there's this move threatening the
Queen and threatening queen tej takes a
h5 and this is completely over Queenie
to black can try covering this
then then then does this move with the
funny point of like takes here check us
this checkmate to need to check made
yeah so this check he needed to go to g8
which looks terrible really because of
this move but yet the other one was even
worse Queen d2 attacking this bishop so
I discovered check would blunder this
piece so this is the great idea Queenie
for though is good centralizing the
Queen and eyeing the g6 pawn rook c1 and
rook f3 of course h5 wasn't a good
target anymore but this looks nice it
puts the rook on the FL and of course
black came up capture here checkmate
made in one so this doesn't help Black
Plague King edge seven and here we have
a very interesting occurrence which is
which is really a really remarkable de-
say look what happened you can look at
this game and turn and let this position
and try to solve this white wins and in
in three moves I keep this for a moment
and now I will show you the solution
stop the video if you want to look for
yourself white played rook f7 Jack which
forces the capture if black would go
here then Sydney is made again so takes
and now wyd found the the very very nice
finish queen takes g6 check sacrificing
the Queen checkmate and this checkmate
very nice the king is checkmated and All
Whites pieces are used in fact he
wouldn't have he wouldn't need to look
actually very nice am those those three
pieces do
the job and what is really remarkable
actually in this position why them can
also play something different he could
could take on g6 at the Queen yeah the
ideas King takes this neck need the same
mate and Knight takes one place night f7
a crook f7 King check me at this mate so
we have some sort of Google solution why
it has two mates and three in this
position they involve the same moves but
they are in a different move order and
we've got different mates with rook f7
and rook the g7 not very nice very nice
really but okay harikrishna our solution
was checklist this meant that I there
showed before and after Queen g67 really
actually I resigned yeah I think I would
have taken and had to see the board it's
really really nice yeah very very
attractive win for Hari Krishna um maybe
I'm black could have gotten even a
better position here instead of this
King g7 plane taking on e4 but this is
really how raising stuff very difficult
to assess I'm very typical of these
sharp sicilian lines okay um it is oft
when I think for high Krishna and the
very cute one at the end with this
checkmate yeah a great round I think
hope you enjoyed it very long video but
it had lots of interesting game some and
and good good content in this round yeah
thanks for watching I'll be back with
round six tomorrow